el día de hoy yo les vengo a platicar de
algo que me apasiona
las fronteras la mayoría de los que
estamos aquí somos fronterizos
quizás excepción de algunos de los
ponentes que vienen de fuera y algunas
gentes que nos están escuchando aquí
pero la mayoría vivimos crecimos o
nacimos en una frontera
y eso nos genera una perspectiva de lo
que es vivir y trabajar y disfrutar de
las fronteras una perspectiva totalmente
distinta a la gente que vive fuera de
ellas
pero muchas gracias a esa perspectiva
no nos permite ver más allá de las dos
ciudades en las que pasamos nuestro
tiempo
y nos ciega a ver cómo podríamos mejorar
esas dos ciudades pensando en ellas como
sólo una
quitándonos cualquier división
o sea física política o cultural que
pudiéramos tener
bueno el día de hoy yo he venido a
platicarles cómo podemos tener un mejor
desarrollo transfronterizo
quisiera empezar con una frase que
quiero que tengan en mente a lo largo de
esta plática que la analicen y que la
tengan ahí presente cuando a mí me la
dijeron
me impactó bastante me hizo pensar en
las fronteras de una manera distinta
a mí me dijeron
las fronteras están marcadas por
perjuicios que se forman de pesadillas
históricas
pesadillas históricas
pesadillas históricas como la guerra
méxico perdió más de la mitad de su
territorio en una guerra con los eeuu la
frontera en la que estamos aquí parados
ahorita está marcada por esa pesadilla
histórica hay nación
si nos vamos un poquito más atrás
tenemos también pesadillas históricas
como la conquista
nuestros destinos como mexicanos y
estadounidenses quedaron marcados desde
que los españoles y los británicos
vinieron a conquistar lo que hoy
conocemos como américa del norte
vemos también el tema de europa está
lleno de pesadillas históricas
a lo largo de los últimos mil años las
fronteras en europa han cambiado
considerablemente
teniendo pasando desde lo que son
i
hasta lo que conocemos ahorita
actualmente como los estados de la unión
europea
tenemos también pesadillas históricas
que se dan de la redistribución de las
tierras
las fronteras del medio oriente que
vemos aquí
fueron dibujadas arbitrariamente por un
enviado del imperio británico y un
enviado del imperio francés que sin
preguntarle a nadie y tomar la opinión
de nadie los que vivían allí
en una mesa asentados así como están
ustedes aquí
dibujaron las fronteras para describir
todavía tienen un impacto al día de hoy
las guerras que se viven en el medio
oriente
muchas son causantes por esas fronteras
las fronteras han estado muy de moda
últimamente también en los medios
tenemos gente que quiere tenemos gente
que quiere construir muros este para
separar a las dos naciones para separar
a la gente que vive en las fronteras
tenemos también el caso
tenemos también el caso de las fronteras
que son de las más peligrosas del mundo
como es el caso de la frontera de corea
del norte y de corea del sur en donde
ahí donde están viendo en ese edificio
que está ahí están teniendo las pláticas
para poder acordar la paz entre las dos
fronteras y esa paz no sólo perjudica a
esa frontera de corea va a tener va a
tener consecuencias en todo el mundo
estamos hablando de una guerra nuclear y
tenemos también el tema de gente que
toma lo que no es de ellos el caso de
rusia que anexó crimea crimea siendo
parte de un país independiente como la
ucrania ahí de plano borraron la
frontera y tomaron
aparte para ellos
pero bueno
quisiéramos ver qué son las fronteras
podemos tomar en cuenta dos perspectivas
podemos ver el lado académico y podemos
ver el lado de los ciudadanos
qué es lo que más me gusta a mí la gente
que vive en las fronteras si vemos el
tema académico
que las fronteras eran una simple
divisiones o barreras físicas llámese un
río una montaña un desierto que separaba
dos países o que separaba dos regiones y
han ido evolucionando hasta gente que ve
las fronteras como oportunidades como
recursos que se pueden tener para tener
un mejor desarrollo
si nos vamos al tema de cómo ven los
ciudadanos las fronteras
tenemos el caso de que los ciudadanos
las ven más desde la óptica de lo que
pasa el día a día
vemos definiciones que te dicen 9 que
sirve que méxico lo consideren como un
país que es una economía emergente sino
si no este soluciona sus problemas de
inseguridad o tenemos el caso también de
quienes nos dicen hoy de qué sirve que
cada quien esté trabajando para su lado
muy bien si no nos ponemos no nos
podemos poner de acuerdo
obtenemos el caso también de quien ve
las fronteras como problemas que viven a
diario nos dicen las fronteras son un
problema de idiomas de lenguajes
pero bueno no todo es malo en las
fronteras vamos a ver por qué importan
las fronteras
en la frontera de méxico y los eeuu
diario cruzan tenemos interacciones
comerciales de más de 1000 millones de
dólares diarios en temas de comercio
exterior
mil millones de dólares en una semana
entre la frontera en méxico de eeuu se
mueve dinero comparable al producto
interno bruto de un país como mónaco
en europa más del 37% de la población
vive en zonas fronterizas
las fronteras son detonantes
demográficos uno de cada tres europeos
vive en una zona fronteriza
y en texas las ciudades fronterizas
crecen a más del doble en cuanto a su
población
a diferencia de la media nacional de los
eeuu es decir las fronteras atraen gente
atrae talento atraen crecimiento atraen
desarrollo
pero a pesar de esta importancia
las fronteras suelen ser caóticas suelen
ser desordenadas suelen ser
problemáticas y muchos de ese caos y
esos problemas se puede definir por unas
barreras a la cooperación
transfronteriza que yo identificado
tenemos barreras políticas barreras
sociales barreras de competencia entre
un lado y otro tenemos barreras de
movilidad de cómo nos transportamos de
un lado de la frontera al otro tenemos
barreras económicas y barreras de idioma
les doy un ejemplo de barreras
culturales en la frontera de francia y
españa- me decían aquí el tema que
tenemos el problema es que tenemos una
cultura empresarial totalmente distinta
del lado francés los empresarios
franceses son seres muy racionales van
por la línea recta y no se mueven de ahí
y mención a la español pues para
ponértela de una manera más fácil
los empresarios son seres latinos que
trabajan con su corazón con su intuición
son más desordenados entonces cuando
tratamos que trabajen esos docentes
empresariales pues es difícil hay
discrepancias
tenemos también el tema de las barreras
del idioma en esa misma frontera de
francia y españa ahí en donde está el
país vasco del lado español y aquitania
del lado francés
ahí se hablan tres idiomas del lado
francés lógico se habla el francés del
lado español se habla el castellano y el
euskera que es el idioma vasco una de
las lenguas más antiguas del mundo hay
cuando quieren hacer cualquier
cooperación tienen que sacar comunicados
en los tres idiomas para que se puedan
entender y para que la gente pueda
entonces ese es una barrera a la
cooperación es una barrera del idioma
tenemos también el tema de barreras
políticas
en la frontera de suecia y dinamarca que
se llama oresund que por cierto es una
de las fronteras más dinámicas del mundo
con más desarrollo y más exitosas pues
ahí también tienen problemas ahí el tema
de la barrera política es que ahí en esa
frontera existen tres gobiernos
regionales que si lo bajamos aquí el
tema de méxico estamos hablando como si
fueran tres gobiernos estatales ahí
existen dos gobiernos del lado de
dinamarca y un gobierno del lado de
suecia y no es que no quieran cooperar
como les digo es una de las fronteras
más exitosas del mundo sino que tienen
que buscar los temas que tengan en común
a parte de las agendas que ellos tienen
y de los compromisos que tienen con sus
votantes temas que tienen en común para
poder cooperar
y tenemos también el tema de barreras
sociales como la que en los últimos años
se ha dado en la frontera entre méxico y
los estados unidos el tema de la
inseguridad en méxico ha distanciado a
las autoridades y a los empresarios
estadounidenses de los mexicanos
haciendo que la cooperación sea un poco
más difícil
pero bueno que propongo que propongo
para ordenar este caos para poder tener
un mejor desarrollo transfronterizo pues
la clave está en todos nosotros la clave
está en las personas la clave está en lo
social
no podemos tener un desarrollo económico
con un desarrollo transfronterizo o
competitividad e innovación si no
partimos de las personas si no partimos
del tema social y para esto yo saqué un
index a un diagrama este y un tema que
se llama base social y la base social
está compuesta por dos temas bastante
mente humanos por un lado tenemos el
capital social que básicamente es cómo
nos relacionamos entre las personas qué
participación tenemos entre grupos
sociales entre nuestras empresas
y del otro lado tenemos la innovación
social la innovación social en cómo
mejoramos en cómo innovamos entre
nuestras relaciones
tenemos una base social si el capital
social genera innovaciones sociales y
tenemos una base social también si ese y
esas innovaciones sociales fortalecen el
capital social y existente
quisiera que se quedaran con tres cosas
del capital social que se necesita para
el desarrollo transfronterizo
necesitamos confianza necesitamos
confiar en nuestros vecinos necesitamos
confiar en la gente con la que
trabajamos
necesitamos redes sociales y no estoy
hablando necesariamente de facebook
twitter o linkedin ese es importante
pero estoy hablando de redes
interpersonales con quién nos
relacionamos con qué grupos participamos
asociaciones empresas y demás esas son
nuestras redes sociales y necesitamos un
tema también de una visión compartida no
podemos hablar cada quien por su lado
debemos de identificar temas en común y
trabajar sobre ellos
les doy un ejemplo de confianza que me
platicaron en la frontera entre francia
y españa hay un organismo para la
cooperación transfronteriza que está del
lado español me decía a nosotros nos
interesa mucho trabajar con nuestros
vecinos franceses y pues veíamos la
necesidad de generar este la confianza
que podíamos tener entre ellos y esa
confianza pues se da con las con las
personas que viven de ambos lados de la
frontera con las personas que comparten
familiares de ambos lados de la frontera
en donde todos se conocen y en donde
todos pueden trabajar de una manera más
más a gusto
tengo el tema también de las redes
sociales en la frontera entre suecia y
dinamarca también me decían bueno
nosotros la mejor manera que pudimos
descubrir para trabajar en este
desarrollo transfronterizo pues fue del
lado sueco nosotros contratamos a un
gerente que era danés que toda su vida
había vivido y estudiado y trabajado del
lado de dinamarca y eso nosotros nos
facilitó muchísimo el intercambio entre
las dos fronteras porque porque íbamos
hacia hacia suecia y pues bueno ya ya
teníamos una cara común ya ya sabíamos
con que estábamos trabajando y esas
redes sociales nos nos facilitaban en la
cooperación transfronteriza
y tenemos también el tema de la visión
compartida en esa misma frontera de
suecia y dinamarca que se llama oración
y que les digo que es una de las más
exitosas pues ahí también tuvieron
problemas con el tema de las últimas
décadas de las de las crisis mundiales y
el tema de la globalización y estuvieron
a punto de perder muchos empleos por
empleos bien remunerados de sectores
como el bioquímico el farmacéutico el de
agroindustria
y allí ellos lo que la decisión que
tomaron es quitarse las dos los dos
países y unirse en uno solo fusionarse y
salir a venderse como una sola cara
pudieron unir sus esfuerzos generaron
una masa crítica mucho más grande de lo
que eran independientemente y salieron a
vender la región ya no como suárez y
dinamarca sino la salieron a vender como
ahora son eso es tener una visión
compartida
en el tema de innovación social quisiera
darles también algunos ejemplos para que
vean de qué estoy hablando cuando la
innovación social en el tema
transfronterizo hay un ejemplo en la
frontera de francia y españa que se
llama euskampus y que es una iniciativa
que nació de la unión de la universidad
del país vasco y del lado español y en
la universidad de burdeos del lado
francés y esta unión lo que hicieron es
que generaron un campus binacional un
campus en donde sus alumnos pueden tomar
cátedra de cualquier lado la frontera
pueden compartir expedientes académicos
pueden compartir mentores pueden
compartir maestros
eso es una innovación social en el tema
educativo y en el tema transfronterizo
tenemos también el tema de la cámara de
comercio e industria de oresund e la de
la frontera entre su escena marca ellos
fueron un poco más allá ellos
evolucionaron ellos sepla no quitaron
las cámaras que existían de cada lado
hicieron una sola y esa cámara de
comercio de oro zoom representa los
intereses de ambos lados de la frontera
es como si nos quitáramos aquí
localmente a la canaco por un lado y al
lado chamber of thames por el otro y
tuviéramos una sala son la cámara de
comercio transfronteriza a eso ha
evolucionado la cooperación
transfronteriza en los países nórdicos
yo los quiero dejar por último con tres
claves para la cooperación
transfronteriza
tres claves o más bien son pasos que
tenemos que seguir para poder llegar a
una mejor cooperación transfronteriza'
si los dejen independientemente me van a
decir que estos igual y se contradicen
pero son etapas por las que tenemos que
pasar necesitamos en primer lugar tener
un poco de informalidad
de informalidad como la que se da aquí
en esta región del área de nuevo laredo
en donde si alguien quiere cooperar es
tan fácil como que cruza la frontera y
se sienta con su contraparte se sientan
y en una servilleta empiezan a escribir
la idea y esa idea se hace en un evento
o se hace en una iniciativa se hace en
algo que es mayor esa informalidad se
necesita para impulsar en un principio
la cooperación de ahí debemos de pasar
al segundo que es la
institucionalización de las acciones de
cooperación transfronteriza
aquí les doy el ejemplo de la unión
europea' y algo que existe que yo llamo
el paraguas europeo ese paraguas europeo
lo que es es que es la existencia de
fondos para la cooperación
transfronteriza de instituciones que
están dedicadas al cien por ciento a
fomentar la cooperación transfronteriza
es mucho más fácil cooperar cuando
existen ese tipo de instituciones y
existe ese tipo de dinero
y el tercero a lo que todos como
fronterizos quisiéramos aspirar es a
evolucionar
y evolucionar a poder llegar y ser
madura mente mentalmente maduros a
podernos quitar lo que no ha funcionado
y a podernos unir y vernos como uno solo
que las acciones no estén dirigidas de
cada lado la frontera sino que las
secciones estén en un solo en un solo
camino
yo los invito a que nos quitemos esas
pesadillas históricas
no a que olvidemos de dónde venimos
pero que mejor estamos trabajando en
construir puentes puentes que nos dan
oportunidades y que esas oportunidades
hagan del desarrollo transfronterizo una
realidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]